denise there's a buzz of excitement as
we count down to virgin hotels
opening the doors not only in the
community but across the street here
at this strip mall with various
businesses anticipating the hotel
benefiting the area overall from more
people to the type of clientele spending
money here
ferraro's predicts a seven to ten
percent boost in sales
the italian restaurant struggled during
the pandemic even
temporarily closing for five months the
owner tells me governor steve sislack
easing pandemic restrictions helped
bring back business
and the hotel opening can only support
that effort
a shoe boutique also expects more foot
traffic because of the new neighbor
i think we'll be good i think we'll see
a lot more people i think a lot of
people have been waiting for something
new especially on this block
various businesses tell me it's been
slow in the shopping complex
not only because of the pandemic but
when hard rock hotel closed
last february to start the virgin
hotel's renovations
ferraros here is also excited because
they're reopening
pizza forte inside virgin hotels for
those who may remember
it was inside hard rock hotel for a few
years
the owner tells me he's done renovations
and he's excited for
the community to see it once again and
get some pizza reporting live outside
virgin hotels kristen drummond 8 news
now